good to see you first of all Flex I've
missed you I think you've changed the
lives of so many people that I know and
it's truly like such a player to be back
such a pleasure to see you grow to sort
of reach so many different aspects of
your own personality thank you for the
love you've always give me some support
and love I just can't I I I'm forever
grateful for that it's lovely to see a
fellow human being who has that love who
basically does not judge people and
there's so many judgmental people out
there and it's just so nice to see these
Beacon of
openness so what makes me one
instantiation of human Irreplaceable do
you think as we enter this increasingly
capable age of increasingly capable AI I
have to ask what do you think makes
humans Irreplaceable so humans are
irreplaceable because of the baggage
that we talked about so we talked about
baggage we talked about the fact that
every one of us
has effectively relearned all of human
civilization in their own way so every
single human has a unique set of genetic
variants that they've inherited some
common some rare and some make us think
differently so make us have different
personalities they say that a a parent
with one child believes in genetics a
parent with multiple children
understands genetics just how different
kids are and my three kids have
dramatically different personalities
ever since the beginning so one thing
that makes us unique is that every one
of us has a different Hardware
the second thing that makes it unique is
that every one of us has a different
software uploading of all of human
Society all of human civilization or
human knowledge we don't we're not born
knowing it we're not like I don't know
uh birds that learn how to make a nest
through genetics and will make a nest
even if they've never seen one we are
constantly relearning all of human
civilization so that's the second thing
and the third one that actually makes
humans very different from AI is that
the baggage we carry is not experiential
baggage it's also evolutionary baggage
so we have evolved through rounds of
complexity
so just like ogres have layers and Shrek
has layers humans have layers
there's the cognitive layer which is
sort of the outer you know most the the
latest evolutionary Innovation these
enormous neocortex that we have evolved
and then there's the emotional uh
baggage underneath that and then there's
all of the fear and fright and flight
and all of these kinds of behaviors so
AI only has a neocortex AI doesn't have
a limbic system it doesn't have this
complexity of human emotions which make
us so I think beautifully complex so
beautifully uh intertwined with our
emotions with our instincts with our you
know sort of gut reactions and all of
that so I think when humans are trying
to suppress that aspect the sort of more
human aspect towards a more cerebral
aspect I think we lose a lot of the
creativity well there's a lot of the you
know freshness of humans and I think
that's quite Irreplaceable so we can
look at the entirety of people that are
live today maybe all humans who have
ever lived and mapped them in this High
dimensional space and there's probably a
center
uh a center of mass for that mapping and
a lot of us deviate in different
directions so the the variety of uh
directions in which we all deviate from
that Center is vast I would like to
think that the center is actually empty
yes that basically humans are just so
diverse from each other that there's no
such thing as an average human
that every one of us has some kind of
complex baggage of emotions intellectual
you know motivational uh behavioral
traits that
um it's not just one sort of normal
distribution we deviate from it there's
just so many dimensions that we're kind
of hitting the sort of sparseness the
the curse of dimensionality where it's
actually quite sparsely populated and I
don't think you have an average human
being so what makes us unique in part is
the diversity
and the capacity for diversity and the
capacity of the diversity comes from the
entire evolutionary history so there's
just so many ways we can vary from each
other yeah I would say not just the
capacity but the inevitability of
diversity basically it's in our Hardware
we are wired differently from each other
my siblings and I are completely
different my kids from each other are
completely different my my wife has
she's like number two of six siblings
from from a distance they look the same
but then you get to you know you get to
know them every one of them is
completely different but sufficiently
the same that the differences interplay
with each other so that's the
interesting thing where the diversity is
functional it's useful so it's like
we're close enough to where we notice
the diversity and it doesn't completely
destroy the possibility of like
effective communication and interactions
so we're still the same kind of thing so
what I said in one of our earlier
podcasts is that if humans realize that
we're 99.9 percent identical we would
basically stop fighting with each other
like we are really one human species and
we are so so similar to each other and
if you look at the alternative if you
look at the next thing outside humans
like it's been six million years that we
haven't had a relative so it's it's
truly extraordinary that that we're
we're kind of like this Dot in outer
space compared to the rest of life on
earth when you think about evolving
through rounds of complexity can you
maybe elaborate such a beautiful phrase
beautiful thought that there's layers of
complexity that make so so with software
sometimes you're like oh let's like
build version two from scratch
but this doesn't happen in evolution in
evolution you layer in additional
features on top of old features so
basically when uh like every single time
my cells divide
I'm a yeast like I'm a unicellular
organism and then cell division is
basically identical
every time I breathe in and my lungs
expand
I'm basically you know like every time
my heart beats I'm a fish so basically
that I still have the same heart like
very very little has changed the blood
going through my veins the oxygen the
you know our immune system we're
basically primates our social behavior
we're basically New World monkeys and
all World monkeys we're basically
um this this concept that every single
one of these behaviors can be traced
somewhere in evolution and that all of
that continues to live within us is also
a testament to not just not killing
other humans for God's sake but like not
killing other species either like just
to realize just how united we are with
nature and that all of these biological
processes have never ceased to exist
they're continuing to live within us and
then just the new cortex and all of the
reasoning capabilities of humans are
built on top of all of these other
species that continue to live breathe
divide metabolize
fight off pathogens all continued inside
us so you think the neocortex the
whatever reasoning is that's the the
latest feature in the in the latest
version of this journey it's it's
extraordinary that humans have evolved
so much in so little time
again if you look at the the timeline of
evolution you basically have billions of
years to even get to a dividing cell and
then a multicellular organism and then a
complex body plan and then these
incredible senses that we have for
perceiving the world the fact that bats
can fly and they evolved flight the
evolved sonar in the span of a few
million years I mean it's just the
extraordinary how much Evolution has
kind of sped up and all of that comes
through this
evolvability the fact that we took a
while to get good at evolving and then
once you get good at evolving you can
sort of
you have modularity built in you have
hierarchical organizations built in you
have all of these constructs that allow
meaningful changes to occur without
breaking the system completely if you
look at a traditional genetic algorithm
the way that humans designed them in the
60s you can only evolve so much and as
you evolve a certain amount of
complexity the number of mutations that
move you away from something functional
exponentially increases and the number
of mutations that move you to something
better exponentially decreases so the
probability of evolving something so
complex becomes Infinity small as you
get more complex but with Evolution it's
almost the opposite
almost the exact opposite that it
appears that it's speeding up exactly as
complex complexity is increasing and I
think that's just the system getting
good at evolving